I think what makes infamous unique among
videogames first and foremost for me is
the the aesthetics of the world I mean
it's just it's just a very very
different and unique game alright and
that translated directly into how we
approach the school foods game
it's burned out blown up destroyed see
so an obvious choice of music style to
match the aesthetics of the game would
be to maybe not go into an orchestral
direction but think of something that's
just a lot more literally gritty so
maybe going after an electronic composer
to create a score for it which is how we
ended up working with David Tobin's
because we we had it in our heads but
the really sophisticated electronica
production that we needed and he was he
was our top choice because nobody really
does it like a man does like the
creative decisions that we made the
aesthetics of the world dictated the
production techniques and we were going
to apply a lot of it was just like a
bunch of found objects so one of the
goals was to take objects that
inherently were non musical and in some
ways or fashion form them into something
that could be used musical and then we
also did the opposite we took musical
objects and made them non-musical and we
created percussion beds out of them
everything in this game is custom
everything was created in there in that
studio or out in the real world we went
to some junkyards we went to a place
where they crush cars and ship the
remnants to China and we did all this
field recording one of my favorite
objects in that in those early field
recordings was um an old I probably from
like the 40s or 50s a pole from a street
lamp and we were putting microphones on
either end of it cuz it was hollow and
then playing little trills little like
rolls and patterns on it with like
rubber
xylophone mallets we bought a Chinese
zither that's called it Jing or a Sheng
I was cleaning out a room in my house
when we were about 3/4 of the way
through the project and I found a big
metal shelving unit and I brought it in
you and we suspended it from from a rack
with bungee cords and that thing was
like a gold mine I mean a lot of the
sort of ambient mood music that's in the
game is just us knocking on this thing
and playing it with bows this kind of
low sounds were actually created with a
concert bass drum that we stretched on G
cords across and we actually plucked and
we'd bang on the drum and pluck the
bungee cord and then we weren't quite
happy with the sound at that point so we
poured dried beans all over and came up
with this sound here by plucking a
bungee cord and then we also had a bunch
of trashcan lids that we were sort of
tapping on and playing with the cello
bows so we got these weird scrapey kind
of looks like wounded sounds we wanted
the city to really sound like it was in
agony
[Music]
we did a lot of work with the
development team early on to come up
with a system that could actually track
how intense the fight would feel to a
player and translate that into musical
terms so what we have here is we have a
piece of combat music that you're
hearing sort of with all its elements
full volume as written and we've got
here all the elements that the composer
had in their piece and stem form and
what we do is we start to group these
elements into high medium and low
intensity elements and then what we can
do is we can fade out say the high
intensity elements when we want to and
then we've still got medium and low
playing and we can take medium down - so
now you're just hearing the low
intensity and sometimes if a piece of
music has like a like an interesting
melody in it or something like that that
melody may sound best in the high
intensity section but we'll put little
pieces of it in the low intensity so
when it fades in it's not a surprise and
it doesn't sound out of place and we're
very conscious to work with the music
after the fact we didn't want the
composer's writing music for this system
of technology we wanted them to just
write great music
[Music]